foreign
howdy y'all my name is dioc and I'm a
customer engineer at Google Cloud hello
everyone my name is Daniel and I'm a
custom engineer at Google Cloud welcome
back to the technical guides for
startups build series
I'm very excited to help you grow your
business successfully and sustainably on
Google Cloud
in our last video we covered excellent
content on analytics and artificial
intelligence jeevanin Hussein introduced
vertex Ai and what it can offer you as
you leverage data to provide for better
customer experiences
the next step in this journey is aimed
at solving the age-old question of how
to modernize an application
to achieve this let's talk about API
management
in this session we'll answer the
following questions
what's an API why do we need apis
managing your apis on Google Cloud API
management with apogee and choosing a
pricing model
we'll show you a demo on how to create
and manage an API with apogee and at the
end we'll look into how apigee supports
a customer with millions of API calls
per second
so let's Dive In
so what is an API API stands for
application programming interface apis
Define the rules of communication
between software applications you can
think of apis as the intermediaries that
standardize access to data between
applications
for example if you have a service
exposing information to the Internet you
may want to control the types of
interactions with data how frequently
resources can be accessed and how to
expose potentially sensitive information
so why do we need API management
as your services grow so will your
consumer base and you will want to
ensure your apis stay consistent and
reliable that your services are
discoverable and well documented and
that services are protected against
threats
now that we agree on one of the API is
why do we need one
first let's look at life without apis
in this example you can see a retailer
and the flow that one of their customers
would go through to use a Retailer's
online services
the customer will initiate a connection
to one of three clients web app mobile
app
or their in-store point of sale system
these clients will in turn consume the
services running in the Retailer's back
end through common user flows such as
adding medicine to their online cart
through their phone making a payment in
store or checking the balance of their
Rewards program through the web app
there are three major issues at play
here inefficient developer workflow
inconsistent customer experience and
difficult infrastructure maintenance
to see how this setup makes developers
work less productively let's observe how
for each client web app mobile and point
of sale the half templement calls to
back-end endpoints separately
even if there's code sharing or some
sort of best practices across the
company
there will be three separate systems
accessing the same resources
on issue number two when a customer acts
as a system through the web app and then
through the mobile app they'll be using
the different implementations that I
just mentioned
and could therefore not have access to
the same information through all the
three clients
imagine this you go to the store trying
to redeem rewards and you find out you
can only do so through your mobile app
where then you're looking for shipping
tracking info on an order that you
placed and you can only find that on the
web app but not the mobile app
finally the third issue is difficulty
maintaining the infrastructure this
arises from the need of the IT team to
support three separate teams each
consuming the endpoints with different
requirements and issues
consider this slight Improvement on the
setup we were looking at before
now each separate client makes requests
to the same Gateway where the apis
establish a structure on what needs to
be passed as input Inwood gets passed as
output
this decoupling of the front and back
end solves the previous issues and
allows for faster changes to both of
these systems
let's take our example even further
let's say you have many of such apis
imagine hundreds of different apis the
issue that arises now can't be fixed
with just having an API Gateway the
challenge now is how to manage all of
these apis at scale having to apply
policies such as rate limiting quotas
and authentication getting rich
visibility through monitoring and
Reporting on API consumption and
productizing apis so that they're no
longer just an interface to data or some
sort of connective tissue between text
systems but instead become a revenue
stream for your business
the solution for these challenges
is moving away from API gateways towards
API management
apogee is a Google Cloud's native API
management solution
although API management encompasses more
than a simpler API Gateway it may not be
the best option for your use case
let's go through this decision tree to
determine when to use one versus the
other
start with where you want to run your
services
if deploying them on Google Cloud you
first determine if you're implementing
them as serverless functions such as
Cloud functions or Cloud run if so then
the recommended route is Google Cloud's
API Gateway
alternatively if you need to manage this
service and run the co-located Gateway
or if you need private networking for
your endpoints the choice is clear Cloud
endpoints
lastly if you need lifecycle API
functionality such as building managing
or securing apis then the choice is
apogee
back to where you can run your services
if you decide to do so in a hybrid
architecture apogee through its hybrid
functionality is the right path
now let's dive in into apogee a bit more
let's explore some of our biggest
features apigee allows you to operate
your apis with enhanced scaled security
and automation you can build apis to
unlock and standardize data from any app
system or service you can secure every
API transaction without overhead using
robust policies and advanced controls
you can monitor and analyze your API
traffic to gain Brazilian performance
and you can create API products to
generate new revenue streams and vibrant
communities
a policy is like a module that
implements a specific function because
they are designed to let you easily add
common types of management capabilities
to an API they can save you time
implementing and maintaining a number of
functionalities for security traffic
management transformation and mediation
with traffic management policies you can
use apogee to minimize latency for apps
while maintaining the health of back-end
services
the spike arrest policy for example
protects against traffic searches this
policy limits the number of requests
processed by an API proxy and sent to a
back end and this protects against
performance lacks and downtime
with transformation policies apigee
makes manipulating messages flowing
through your API proxy simple for
example you can use the XML to Json or
XSL transform policies to make it easier
to transform messages between formats or
you can use the assign message policy to
create messages from variable values and
use the extract variable policy to
assign variables from message content
you're not limited to the set of policy
types provided by apogee you can write
custom scripts using JavaScript for
example and this allows you to innovate
on basic management capabilities
thanks Daniel
API security is a growing concern as API
traffic rose with ever increasing attack
vectors it's critical for the operations
team to protect the data flowing through
every API transaction with fine grain
control
apogee enables you to enforce consistent
security best practices and governance
policies detect bot attacks and analyze
potential threats with AI powered
monitoring to protect your data against
the most common security threats
apogee is also seamlessly integrated
with Google Cloud security products for
example it's easy to combine apogee with
Cloud armor and recaptcha for a full web
application and API protection solution
the rule of monitoring here is to ensure
apis are always available secure and
Performing as it's expected
API monitoring provides near real-time
insights into API traffic and
performance to help you one quickly
diagnose and solve issues as they arise
by letting you create alerts on changes
in API traffic so you can take
appropriate action before customers are
affected two increase API availability
and reduce the mean time to diagnosis
mttd through quick investigations
three
leverage fault codes to speed up
diagnosis and four isolate problem areas
quickly to diagnose errors performance
and latency issues and their sources APD
offers developer portal solutions that
enable app developers to learn about
their data and service offerings learn
how to use your apis about review and
documentation including example use
cases tutorials and reference
documentation register a self-service
process in order to build apps that use
your apis
you will learn more about the developer
portal later in this video
that's quite a bit of info on apogee if
this sounds like what you're looking for
then the next step is to determine how
to consume it
there are two pricing models
a subscription that has tiers
and you can choose which tier is best
for use case
in a newly added pay as you go model
this new model has no upfront costs and
requires no commitment
the charges will be based solely on your
usage of three things
apogee Gateway nodes per minute which
are units of an environment that
processes the API traffic
two total number of API requests
processed by apogee analytics whether
the requests are successful or not and
three General Google Cloud networking
costs which are not specific to apigee
next up we'll show you a demo on how to
create and manage apis with apogee in
this demo we'll create an API proxy and
attach policies to increase the utility
of our apis
to recreate this demo you'll need to
provision an apigee X organization
so you will find a useful Hands-On lab
and tutorial in the video description
let's create a simple API proxy using
the apogee UI
for this you can visit apigee.google.com
open the apigee UI and use the menu on
the left side to navigate to the API
proxy section
and here you'll see API proxies listed
for your environment at the moment would
have any let's create a new one
since we'll be routing inbound traffic
to a back-end service we'll select the
reverse proxy for this example
now we configure the proxy and I'm gonna
give it the name my proxy
automatically the base path is set to
the same name apigee uses this as part
of the URL to match and Route incoming
traffic incoming requests to the proper
API proxy
now we enter the target URL that apigee
invokes on a request to the API proxy
since we're creating a new service for
this demo we'll use the mock Target
service hosted at apigee to return
simple data
on the common policy screen select pass
through as the security option
we won't configure any other policies
for now
for creating the proxy we must deploy it
to use it let's navigate to API proxies
on the left hand menu
we'll select the created proxy
and then we select deploy for the dialog
to the deploy dialog to appear
we're prompted to select the revision
number of the proxy the environment to
deploy it and optionally you can specify
a service account
we'll see the sign of a successful
deployment under the status column under
deployment once this is completed
Let's test out deployment by calling the
proxy
for this we need to locate the
environment Group hostname by navigating
to using the left hand menu
using admin
and we're going to go to environment
and groups
for this example the environment group
hostname was set up during provisioning
using a wild card service so the
environment group hostname is this IP
address
dot nip.io where the IP address
corresponds to The Host
now we make a curl request to call the
proxy
and a successful call to the proxy
should return a sample data in XML
format as you can see here
a policy is an apigee component that you
can attach to different points in the
message flow through API proxies
in this demo we're adding the XML to
Json policy to our proxy
this policy converts the payloads of an
XML message to Json it also changes the
responses content type header
we'll first create an instance policy
the following way
using the left menu we navigate to API
proxies
and select the desired proxy
we go to the develop tab
and on the left hand pane we click the
plus button next to policies
this allows us to search for the XML to
Json policy
we're allowed to name it too
for this specific policy
we have created the policy and now we
attach the policy to a step in the free
flow policies in the pre-flo are
executed before any other policies in
the proxy
so we're going to select proxy endpoints
default prefall pre-flow in the left
hand pane
if we click the plus button next to
preflow in the response pane at the
bottom right
and we add the just created policy
we save the current revision
and deploy
now let's test this new policy using a
curl command
we can see the response in Json format
with a Json content type header in the
response
is the world's leading weather media and
Big Data company serving nearly 2
billion people and more than 30 billion
API data requests daily AccuWeather
productizes their weather API with
apogee
making it easy for developers to use
weather data in their own apps
the AccuWeather API developer portal
allows easy access to the most accurate
detailed weather data to develop
Innovative new weather experiences
here's what markianelli senior technical
account manager had to say about
apogee's developer portal
single developer always has the
potential to be working on the next big
thing and become our next big Enterprise
partner
we needed a way to reach them and the
AccuWeather API developer portal powered
by apogee accomplishes that
thanks for watching this video and for
staking through the end
if you'd like to know more about apogee
or more generally API Management on
Google Cloud then check out the
resources with the links in the
description of the video
you can explore the apogee documentation
watch more in-depth demonstrations of
apogee you can even get Hands-On with
our online courses through Cloud skills
boost in particular a great lab which
guides you through deploying apis in
apogee and how they look on the
developer portal
finally don't hesitate to reach out if
you'd like to work with us on how apogee
can help your business
in the next video of this series we'll
take you through security commence
Center SEC for short some use cases of
it a demo and an inspiring customer
story
at the end we'll talk through briefly
about activeassist and how you can use
it to optimize your usage of cloud
resources
as always don't forget to like this
video And subscribe to our YouTube
channel
make sure to click on the Bell icon to
get notified every time a new video gets
posted
thank you so much and stay tuned for
more on how you can build your startup
on Google Cloud
[Music]